these animals are characters they have a
story they have families and you really
were so clever in the way you made it
you really brought it to life every
creature has a story try bring that
story to life for everyone some of the
shots it was like you were living with
these animals I mean I don't know how
you got the shot overtop of the Panda I
don't know how can you describe sort of
how you got some of that footage
well these cinematographers are amazing
Shane Moore who is the cinematographer
for all the snow leopards footage
it took him 90 days to get his for a
shot because what he does is studies the
patterns the movements the behaviors
same thing with the pandas the
cinematographers literally donned panda
costume no way and their themselves with
panda sense shall we say so that they
could and they essentially then kind of
fit into the community they have to
build the trust with the animal as
they're filming John Krasinski obviously
does a great job narrating the film and
the way he tells the story
eg Ori has a beautiful kind of arc there
had to be so much footage how much what
did you go through verses because you
picked the perfect quote but a perfect
shot the perfect narration there would
tell this story 400 hours of footage for
a 75 minute film Wow
there's that one shot of the birth of
it's your own and it's just like one of
the most beautiful aliens you've ever
seen well I loved loved loved loved
loved this movie how can we get
everybody to see this you and I need to
collaborate first weekend if you're the
percentages for every every ticket there
is a contribution to the World Wildlife
Fund and we want we want to save pandas
we want to save snow leopards and it's
it's a wonderful thing that Disney does
[Music]
you